a juste en face de vous s'est installé
Charles instant tool bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous bon ça vous êtes député
renaissance du Bas-Rhin et vous aviez
deux thèmes sur lesquels vous souhaitiez
interroger Bertrand pencher les
retraites et tchuss France vous voulez
commencer par quoi on va commencer par
lire très vite parce que je crois que
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
bonsoir Bertrand pencher bonsoir alors
moi je suis jeune député j'ai été lui il
y a quelques mois et je viens d'une
terre historiquement centriste de la
démocratie chrétienne ou l'UDF a été
très longtemps je crois un parti que
vous vous connaissez bien alors moi
depuis plusieurs mois j'ai beaucoup
d'anciens amis de l'UDF qui qui me pose
cette question que je vais relayer ici
pourquoi est-ce que des personnes comme
Bertrand pencher et Charles de Courson
sa coquine avec l'extrême gauche contre
une réforme sérieuse qui la réforme des
retraites qui storiquement la famille à
laquelle vous appartenez à toujours
soutenu voilà moi d'abord je voudrais
répondre que
nous nous accoquinons avec avec personne
signée nous nous représentons nous nous
sommes un groupe commentaires
indépendants avec des élus ici et des
élus du des territoires et notre groupe
parlementaire joue son rôle je trouve
que ça serait quand même fort de café
qu'on puisse pas prendre position sur un
projet de loi de ce type qui est
important pour nous pour nos concitoyens
nos concitoyens nous interpellent nous
interpellent en permanence
j'ajoute que moi je le fais de façon
complètement transparente puisque
lorsque je me suis présenté aux
élections législatives j'ai dit à mes
concitoyens que j'étais opposés à cette
augmentation unie enfin uniforme de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite donc
je suis c'est vraiment conforme à mes
engagements en ayant soutenu un mois
avant Valérie Pécresse qui défendait la
retraite à 60 ans avant François Fillon
à comprendre ce genre de tête à queue en
quelques semaines
je pense que pour un parachute je crois
me souvenir que vous étiez à LR
soutenu aussi défendez défendez la
retraite à 65 ans oui mais peut-être bon
peut-être aussi en changeant
d'engagement politiquement face à votre
enfin c'est votre coin évidemment c'est
votre c'est votre droit moi je ne me
suis jamais caché y compris pendant la
campagne présidentielle de mon
opposition à cette augmentation de l'âge
légal de la retraite parce que je vois
bien mes concitoyens qui n'en peuvent
plus mais être soignante mais aide à
domicile m'a caissière de supermarché
qui m'a encore interpellé il y a
quelqu'un il y a quelques jours sur
cette grave injustice je pense qu'il y
avait d'autres moyens de financer ce
système il suffisait d'écouter les
organisations syndicales je pense
notamment la CFDT qui était qui avait
des propositions on est à 15 milliards
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
15 milliards de dépenses pendant combien
avons-nous aggraver la dette de la
France ces dernières années de 600 il y
avait une réforme de 6 600 milliards
rétablir de 600 milliards avec des
mesures qui n'était pas forcément très
très juste on prive la France de
recettes fiscales de 50 milliards
d'euros à travers des tas d'exonération
qu'on aurait pu rendre plus juste c'est
à dire les cibler vers les populations
les plus en difficulté que de les faire
de façon complètement unilatérale et là
600 milliards de dettes c'est quand même
pas mal
une crise 50 milliards mais on aurait pu
on aurait pu nous avons fait des
propositions vous venez d'arriver ici à
l'Assemblée nationale nous avons fait
des propositions pour cibler en
direction des personnes qui en avait le
plus les plus besoin vous comme moi bon
la réforme des de la fiscalité locale on
aurait pu continuer à payer nos impôts
vous comme moi on aurait pu continuer à
payer la redevance télévision bien je
pense que nous avons fait des
propositions vous savez
nous avons fait des propositions nous
avons fait des propositions pour cibler
notamment ces
exonérations ces exonérations fiscales
bon ça n'a pas été le cas possible c'est
15 milliards je rappelle que c'est 15
milliards dans le pire des cas le corps
2030 on n'était pas à quelques mois près
pour trouver une solution nous avons
fait des propositions la raison pour
laquelle nous engageons encore à
relancer une conférence sociale moi je
pense qu'en prenant un peu de temps on
serait arrivé à cette solution là et je
pense que votre gouvernement et votre
majorité n'aurait pas été aussi
impopulaire si c'était donné un petit
peu le temps de la réflexion le passage
en force sa fragilise la démocratie si
la note de la France vient de baisser
c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas réussi à
passer en force c'est parce qu'on est en
incapacité de réformer et d'écouter sur
sur les retraites l'autre sujet qui va
arriver dans trois semaines c'est donc
la proposition de loi que nous aurons à
discuter le 8 juin il y a un problème
majeur dans cette proposition là à mon
sens elle est en constitutionnel
au regard de l'art parents de la
Constitution que connaissent pas
forcément tous nos concitoyens mais
c'est le moment de le dire qui dit très
clairement qu'une proposition de loi ne
peut pas aggraver les charges publiques
et là on parle de 15 milliards d'euros
qui ne sont pas financés voilà on a gagé
ça en termes techniques sur le tabac
voilà tout ça tout ça n'est pas très
sérieux donc moi j'aimerais que vous
nous expliquez comment est-ce qu'on
change cette proposition de l'article 40
de la
constitutions
demain lors de la réunion groupe qu'on
aura au sein de la majorité moi je le
considère que c'est proposition de loi à
15 milliards d'euros qui n'est pas
financé elle est irrecevable au titre de
l'article 40 donc comment est-ce que
vous financez ces 15 milliards d'euros
d'abord chers collègues moi je vous dis
le texte
moi je vous donnerai pas le conseil de
tenter de faire de l'obstruction
parlementaire sur un sujet non non mais
je vous le dis je vous le dis quand même
parce que vous allez allumer vraiment un
bâton de dynamite les Français sont
accros devant Brigitte il y a quelques
jours j'ai dit que moi je considérais
que c'était pas bonne
c'est vraiment un bâton de dynamite on
est d'accord 16 et les Français veulent
faire en sorte qu'on aille jusqu'au bout
et qu'on vote et qu'on vote et moi je
défends le Parlement jamais jamais
fait c'est mon 4e mandat de
parlementaire jamais j'ai vu une
proposition de loi ou de d'origine
parlementaire où on a opposé cet article
40 jamais alors si on change le
règlement parce que c'est le groupe
liote qui dépose un projet de loi qui
embarrasse le gouvernement et sa
majorité je peux vous dire que le remède
va être plus que vont plus terrible que
le mal deuxième observation deuxième
observation nous nous faisons la
proposition d'une conférence sociale
pourquoi une conférence sociale parce
que les partenaires sociaux il faut les
mettre ensemble pour trouver des
solutions de financement et nous pensons
que nous pouvons à travers une
conférence sociale ouvrir des
possibilités de de financement de
calendrier regardez quand même cette
absurdité enfin c'est un truc
complètement dingue vous voulez vous
nous confirmer que vous avez déposé un
texte vous ne savez pas comment le
financer ce que vous dites que vous
voulez faire une conférence sociale plus
tard c'est un peu c'est un peu de votre
raisonnement prenez pas ne prenez pas
des des jeux comme ça on parle de 15
milliards d'euros je suis pas né de la
dernière pluie on a fait des
propositions de financement notre
système de retraite à travers la foi
l'augmentation de la comment
l'augmentation de fin l'accélération de
la réforme Touraine c'est une idée des
pistes de complet de commandes des
pistes de financement complémentaires
nous nous voulons faire en sorte que la
démocratie sociale joue comment joue son
rôle et nous fasse des propositions vous
allez quand même pas me faire croire à
un seul moment d'y faire croire un seul
moment aux françaises et aux Français
qu'augmenter deux ans la fin là je
départ à la retraite alors qu'il y a
déjà 40% de personnes de chaudes de
chômeurs qui qui partent qui partent en
retraite sont un vaste plan Seigneur qui
a été par votre majorité qui a été
complètement
rognée dans le cadre de la navette de la
navette
mais ça va revenir dans un projet de loi
travail
un débat de qualité à l'Assemblée
nationale qui a été en grande partie
obstruée par vos alliés du moment
d'extrême gauche on aurait peut-être pu
approfondir un peu plus le sujet
effectivement attendez le débat de
qualité on n'était pas deux ou trois
mois près pour discuter ce 47 ans
manuel Macron deuxième tour des
élections présidentielles je vais
commencer d'ailleurs par finir leur par
leur gratter s'il continue comme ça j'ai
voté par Emmanuel Macron deuxième tour
des élections présidentielles alors que
parallèlement je m'étais engagé à ne pas
voter cette augmentation de l'âge légal
de départ très et il y en a beaucoup qui
ont été comme ça
par défaut pour Emmanuel Macron mais
contre la fin pas pour sa réforme des
retraites c'est ce que vous dites
et je vais vous dire chers collègues ça
serait un grand service si vous comme
les autres nous aidiés à faire en sorte
que cette loi passe parce que ça
permettrait de désenbourber la situation
du pays et pendant quatre ans de réussir
à mettre en place des réformes basées
sur le dialogue nous on ne demande que
ça à travailler il y aura un vote en
tout cas le 8
juin
demain il y aura une stratégie et vous
allez en discuter dès demain il y avait
un autre thème sur lequel vous souhaitez
interroger Bertrand brancher surtout
France qui avait lieu aujourd'hui à
Versailles de la République a explique
la cohérence de notre action économique
avec l'accent mission de l'industrie et
je sais que par ailleurs je crois que
vous êtes un spécialiste des questions
d'environnement donc vous avez peut-être
vu le discours qui qu'il a commis il y a
quelques jours et donc où il l'explique
l'importance
d'accélérer la transition énergétique
par par l'industrie donc il y aura un
texte industrie verte qui arrivera à
l'Assemblée dans quelques jours semaines
donc voilà comment est-ce que vous vous
envisagerez vous vous ce texte ce que
vous le considérez important est-ce que
vous reconnaissez aussi voilà que sur
l'industrie nous avons réussi à arrêter
en tout cas l'hémorragie et à faire
repartir aussi la dynamique industrielle
de notre pays ça m'intéresserait de vous
entendre là-dessus oui c'est un texte
qui est effectivement important je pense
qu'il faut essayer de faire revenir des
des grandes entreprises et
réindustrialiser notre pays je pense
qu'on part quand même très loin que je
pense que le
il échappe à personne que le déficit
commercial a jamais été aussi important
dans notre pays je crois le pire déficit
commercial depuis 1947 48 comme on
semble-t-il bon après je mets en garde
les uns et les autres de faire des
cocorico je pense qu'il faut aussi
pouvoir rester modeste c'est bien de
s'engager dans cette direction il y a
encore beaucoup de réformes à faire
peut-être que j'aurais pas conseillé non
plus à Emmanuel Macron d'organiser une
réception à Versailles pour ce que
l'image vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens et
peut-être pas la meilleure
en
[Musique]
communications internationaux et pour
les pour les étrangers c'est vrai que
Versailles est un des lieux symboliques
du pays et pour attirer des gens qui
vont investir des millions voir parfois
des centaines de millions d'euros
Versailles est un lieu voilà qui qui qui
n'est pas neutre et qui est symbolique
et qui fonctionne manifestement
sur cette question de l'industrie verte
vous avez d'autres questions là un peu
plus un peu plus précise parce que dans
ce qu'a dit le président il y a quelques
jours il a notamment parlé de crédit
d'impôts que nous pourrions être amenés
à créer pour favoriser les
investissements dans les batteries les
pompes à chaleur les éoliennes les
panneaux solaires de créer une sorte de
crédit d'impôt industriel verte est-ce
que vous pensez au lac c'est quelque
chose qui va qui va dans le bon sens aux
gens de discuter nous avons discuté avec
Bruno Le Maire c'est bon c'est
effectivement des propositions qui vont
dans le format moi je suis pas là pour
tout critiquer quand même
ça veut dire que
ce projet de loi industrie vertes
nous en discutons ensemble
il faut évidemment tout faire en sorte
pour réindustrialiser notre pays
voir également combien coûte cette
accompagnement financier parce que les a
parlé je crois de 20 milliards
commandent 20 milliards d'euros moi je
me méfie toujours avec les promesses
financières
il faut regarder ensuite comment nous
allons pouvoir décliner décliner tout ça
parce que le gouvernement sait faire à
travers des des sommes qui sont parfois
difficiles donc on va demander
évidemment pouvoir tracer ces dépenses
et ses engagements pour pour les
entreprises
on va on va étudier ce texte là le
moment venu j'attire quand même votre
attention sur le fait que on s'était
engagé à concerter
tous les groupes parlementaires dans le
cadre des projets de loi de futurs pour
celui-là malheureusement on vient de
nous présenter sans que nous ayons été
associés en amont à cet ex de loi donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle on est
pour le moins un petit peu prudent sur
nos prises de position merci chers